this video is kindly sponsored by
curiosity stream the subscription
streaming service that offers thousands
of documentaries and non-fiction titles
from some of the world's best filmmakers
hey 42 here great britain and the usa
have always been the closest of allies
and over the last couple of centuries
we've done all the things good allies do
together
we've traded goods shared knowledge
enjoyed our respective cultures
and waged a few dubious wars
we're the country equivalent of bffs
best buds comrades in arms partners in
crime friends with benefits
whoa where did that last one come from
anyway the us and great britain get on
so well our geopolitical alliance even
has a name
the special relationship coined by none
other than winston churchill in 1946
seriously which other nations have a
whole wikipedia page
dedicated to how well they get on
to be fair i probably shouldn't say that
britain and the us have always been
close allies i mean we have been to war
with each other once or twice
by far the biggest of those conflicts
was the revolutionary war
fought for america's independence from
the british empire between
1775 and 1783
and it was during that world altering
scrap
that something unique happened
for the first and only time in history
the united states launched a physical
assault
against britain's shores
although some historians argue that a
second assault occurred in 1999 when the
backstreet boys toured england
this monumental attack against britain
was planned and executed by a man named
nick carter oh sorry wrong one
the attack was planned and executed by
john paul jones
if you know your american military
history that name will no doubt be very
familiar to you because mr jones is
considered to be one of the fathers of
the us navy alongside john adams and
john barry
despite his lofty position in u.s
military law
john paul jones was
to be frank
a bit of a nut case
in leading the first and only american
attack to land troops on mainland
britain
jones was pitting himself against the
most powerful military force on earth
and yet he didn't choose to take on the
royal navy at the head of a mighty
armada
no he attacked the british isles
with a single ship
uss ranger
curiosity stream is the world's first
streaming service addressing our
lifelong quest to learn explore and
understand if like me you're into
history then you definitely need to
check out their content packed history
selection but history is only a small
part of their enormous collection with
content spanning science nature history
technology society and lifestyle
it really is the new netflix for nerds
hulu for history buffs and the disney
plus for the scientists in all of us
they're adding more exciting content all
the time and despite having an enormous
amount of titles curiosity stream is
extremely affordable at under 20 a year
and it's available worldwide and on
practically every device one of my
favorite shows is google and the world
brain it's a fascinating look behind the
scenes at google's attempt to scan and
digitize every single book in the world
but it raises some interesting and
controversial questions about what they
plan to do with it all so if you're
anything like me and you want to take
away more from the programs you're
watching then go to
curiositystream.com forward slash 42 for
unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series and
if you use promo code 42 you'll save 25
off which comes out to only 14.99 a year
that's just 125 per month
so click the link below or go to
curiositystream.com forward slash 42 and
save 25 right now which is only 14.99
for a whole year an unbelievable price
for such an incredible wealth of content
at what can only be described as a bit
of a numerical disadvantage
jones obviously couldn't attempt a
full-blown invasion
instead he planned to use ranger to sew
his own distinctive brand of chaos
disrupting britain's forces as much as
he possibly could
to begin with that all went rather well
with rangers successfully sinking
several supply ships in the english
channel but jones wasn't satisfied
after all the royal navy was huge and
picking off the odd supply vessel here
and there was more of an annoyance than
a genuine problem and so jones made a
remarkable decision if he wanted to deal
the empire a truly telling blow he was
going to have to invade the mainland
jones chose the port of whitehaven as
the target of this attack
around 400 ships were moored there at
the time and if he and his men could
sneak ashore
under cover of darkness
a few strategically placed fires could
achieve in minutes what would take years
to do out on the open ocean
you have to hand it to him attacking a
well-armed port town with a single ship
was incredibly bold
but boldness alone
doesn't mean a plan will be successful
as john paul jones was about to find out
[Music]
i should probably point out that jones
didn't choose whitehaven solely because
of the large number of ships moored
there
there was another more important reason
during the early part of his maritime
career
jones had been based at whitehaven and
he knew that port like the back of his
hand knowledge he could use to his
advantage during the attack
if you're wondering why a decorated
american military captain had once been
based at an english port
that simple despite his subsequent
infamy for spearheading the us's only
direct attack on british soil in history
john paul jones
was actually a brit himself
he didn't leave blighty until the age of
23 and even then it wasn't exactly
voluntary he was fleeing murder charges
after killing two members of his own
crew during two separate mutinies
so as jones sailed ranger towards wide
haven he began to construct a plan based
on his near perfect knowledge of the
port and the waters around it
the way he saw it torching whitehaven
ships
should be relatively easy apart from one
small problem
two actually
the twin forts that guarded the harbour
entrance
one to each side
jones was confident the forts wouldn't
stop him getting in
never in their wildest dreams did the
brits expect an american attack on home
soil
so there was practically no chance of
lookouts being present during the night
when jones planned to attack
but getting out would be another matter
entirely
as soon as jones's men set fire to
whitehaven's fleet the alarm would be
raised and within minutes the fort's
many cannons would be scanning the sea
for enemy ships
uss ranger
would be sunk for sure
jones didn't have enough men to capture
the forts
and
that left him with only one option
he was going to have to them
on the night of the attack jones split
his force in two and instructed his men
to sneak into the forts and spike the
cannons
literally ram steel spikes into a small
opening known as a touch hole
rendering the fearsome weapons
completely useless
this first part of the plan went off
without a hitch
though unfavorable tides meant getting
to the fort took longer than expected
that shouldn't have been a problem there
was still plenty of time to engage in a
spot of good old-fashioned arson but
it was here that the mission hit its
first major snack the men's lanterns had
run out of fuel
meaning they had no way of setting
whitehaven ships on fire
these days some helpful smoker would
probably have pulled out a lighter or a
match and all would have been well but
this was 1778 and neither lighters nor
matches had been invented yet
by the way the cigarette lighter was
invented in 1823
three years before the friction match
how's that for a random interesting fact
anyway
jones and his men had whitehaven ships
at their mercy
but
they had nothing to set them on fire
with
luckily jones's local knowledge once
again came to the fore he knew there was
a public house on the harbour front that
would be sure to have plenty of spare
fuel on hand
jones julie dispatched his men to raid
the pub
and raided the pub is exactly what they
did
of beer
despite the fact they were in the middle
of a daring mission on enemy soil and
would no doubt be killed on the spot if
anyone caught them
once inside the pub
the men simply couldn't resist a quick
pint
by the time they returned with the fuel
the sun was beginning to rise and time
was running out
in an effort to do the maximum damage to
whitehaven ships in the shortest time
possible
jones focused his efforts on a heavily
laden coal ship named thompson reasoning
that if the coal went up the ensuing
inferno will quickly spread to the rest
of the closely packed ships in the
harbour
triggering an unstoppable chain reaction
that would destroy the entire fleet
it was a sound plan
but unfortunately for john paul jones
he never got to find out if it would
have worked
because one of his crew a chap by the
name of daniel freeman was hiding a
secret
he hadn't signed up to america's
continental navy to fight the british
he'd simply been trying to get free
passage across the atlantic
you see
freeman
was irish
and he had no intention of letting
whitehaven ships go up in smoke
as jones and his men began lighting
strategic fires on board the thompson
the rebel irishman snuck away towards
the town
where he promptly began banging on every
door he could to alert the locals to the
attack within minutes most of the men in
whitehaven had descended on the harbour
vastly outnumbered by the growing mob of
angry pajama-wearing englishmen
jones was forced to call an immediate
retreat
he was able to escape without any
casualties the townsfolk were unable to
fire the spiked cannons as jones had
planned
but just one of the 400 ships in
whitehaven harbour was on fire the
thompson and the modest blaze was
extinguished in a matter of minutes with
little damage caused the us's first and
only assault on the british isles
backstreet boys aside
had ended in failure
but jones had no intention of returning
home empty-handed
true there was no way he could scup a
deflated whitehaven without the element
of surprise on his side any longer but
he did have a plan b
[Music]
just 25 miles north of whitehaven across
the solway firth
is a small coastal town by the name of
kirk cubright
having been born just 20 miles to the
east
john paul jones knew it well
he also knew to the south of kirkhof
bright lived a man by the name of dumbar
douglas
better known as the forefeel of selkirk
jones reasons that the british might be
prepared to hand over a large number of
captured american soldiers in return for
said earth
and so having failed at arson jones
decided to have a go at kidnapping
this being a far more civilized time
when jones sent two of his men to nab
the earl on arrival at kurt cutbright
they didn't burst in all guns blazing
they simply walked up to the front door
of the grand selkirk estate
and knocked
it was the butler who answered naturally
and there would be kidnappers were
invited into the drawing room where they
were given tea
as a brit myself i can confirm
that there is literally no social
situation that can't be made less
awkward by tea
even a kidnapping
lady selkirk the woman of the house was
summoned to entertain the guests
but pleasant though the little
pre-kidnapped tea party was the sailors
were keen to get down to business
unfortunately it soon became clear
abducting the earl was going to be
rather more difficult than they'd
expected
on account of him not actually being in
the country at the time
luckily lady selkirk was a true believer
in the importance of hospitality
she didn't want her guests to leave
disappointed
and since kidnapping was out of the
question she suggested they might want
to steal the family silver instead
the sailors agreed and they were soon on
their way back to the ranger with a sack
full of loot
but when they presented said loot to
captain jones some time later
it became clear that there had been more
to lady selkirk than met the eye
because apart from several ornate and
expensive silver plates engraved with
the selkirk coat of arms the bulging
sack had been mostly full of coal
to make matters even worse whilst jones
had apparently been pretty comfortable
with arson and kidnapping it seems he
considered stealing to be the height of
rudeness
he did reluctantly allow his crew to
keep the silver but seven years later he
would buy it back at an auction in
france before returning it to the earl
and his wife accompanied by a
handwritten apology
[Music]
whilst it's true that both the attack on
whitehaven and the kidnapping of the
earl of selkirk ended up being a bit of
a bust i'd be doing john paul jones a
gross disservice to suggest his one-ship
raid on the british isles was a failure
in fact the very next day after the
bungled kidnapping
jones led ranger to victory in ship to
ship combat against a royal navy vessel
drake in what was the first american
naval victory of the revolutionary war
in atlantic waters
the capture of drake and more
importantly jones's willingness to
strike at the very heart of the empire
in spite of the overwhelming odds
stacked against him
dealt an important psychological blow to
the british who had up until that point
considered themselves pretty much
untouchable
and more than that
jones's incredible bravery became a
symbol of america's unbreakable spirit
during a war that would eventually bring
about her freedom
[Music]
thanks for
watching good news you can now pre-order
my new book bread and circuses what did
the romans ever do for us
it's a wild and witty journey for a
thousand years of unexpected roman
history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in thank you